comenzó en realidad es imposible
acercarse las fuerzas rusas han lanzado
un aluvión de bombas la estratégica
ciudad ubicada a unos 15 kilómetros de
la capital kiev está bajo una lluvia de
fuego las explosiones se oyen
constantemente estos soldados ucranianos
regresan del frente de batalla agotados
y en silencio este grupo de jóvenes
voluntarios está angustiados
[Música]
pero para llegar al vehículo tendrán que
volver a donde se librarán los combates
estos voluntarios van a arriesgar sus
vidas para intentar recuperar el coche
esta misma mañana
cientos de metros los civiles habían
comenzado a huir de la ciudad en
relativa calma luego horas después
[Música]
los habitantes siguieron siendo
evacuados a lo largo del día pero en una
situación peligrosa está ambulancia está
llena de gente que huye del bombardeo
adultos mayores familias niños
desde el autobús gritos de vida Ucrania
y alivio para los que consiguieron
escapar del infierno
la batalla por la ciudad aún no ha
terminado pero los rusos han dejado
Claro que la tomaran cueste lo que
cueste